man you know what uh you know what the
hardest thing about being an adult is i
realized the other day
go on youngest one here so you said my
mom or something
i was like that's her
daddy what is it something that you
can't be prepared for as a child
something that you you don't get exposed
to menopause
yes
obviously picture it i was at my uh my
local bakery and uh i go to go and get
my favorite item
they changed the recipe
they changed the item it's no longer the
same it's they substituted the the
the materials that made this fantastic
piece of food what are the kids called
that again pain picker yeah you know no
one prepares you for your favorite food
items at a fast food chain or a food
place changing i agree how do you deal
with that how do you cope with it i can
do one better okay so you go to a
restaurant it's a local restaurant it's
like a it's like a local you know local
restaurant that's not a chain or
anything it's just it's your local
restaurant right and then one day you go
there and for some reason you don't know
why the food just tastes different right
the food just doesn't hit as hard you
can't you can't put your you can't put
your like finger on why until you
realize oh the chef's gone somewhere
else that food will never taste the same
ever again because it's gone
independently because because it was the
chef all the time that made the food
taste good it wasn't the restaurant
myself actually had that in japan once
and it was so [ __ ] tragic i never
wanted to cry more while eating food in
my life i'm like this doesn't taste bad
but
my childhood it's just yeah over there
i i agree that's bad but i think the
fast food one's worse because the fast
food is like comfort you know you always
go to get the same thing with fast food
that's what you're selling points no i
think the local restaurant
no no it's it's like it's like uh it's
like a person who murdered your best
friend it's just wearing their skin and
then he walks into your house and he's
just pretending to be your best friend
and he's just like not your friend
so it's me
so mcdonald's did this uh this like in
japan there's a problem with with japan
and you get these amazing seasonal items
or items that come around is that they
only last like three weeks so when you
find an absolute banger of a food item
on a menu yeah you know the time is
ticking but that but that like you're
okay with it leaving because you you
knew the rules of the game when you went
in to order that you knew that you were
about to get hurt but you did you didn't
care you wanted that spicy you knew the
rules you knew
that cause i was thinking
when there's an item that has been there
for like ages we're talking like yeah by
the slice yes and then [ __ ] you and then
and then the food item changes you have
been doing this your whole life you've
been eating there you've been getting
this one item and it changes it feels
like a betrayal of the century like
you've got to murdered my family you
walk in you look at the menu and you
just
say what do you mean where is it gone
why would they do this now this must be
a mistake i'll have this item they said
they don't have it i cry no this must be
a mistake please check the back check
the back there must be some left please
no i do still think the local restaurant
is the local restaurant it's the worst
cause you move you move all the time now
you have you experienced it though yeah
it was like a local [ __ ] move no
which one you call what do you mean you
move look if it's a local restaurant i'm
you move every [ __ ] two years gone
no no no i mean like the local
restaurant which is like the same people
running the restaurant it's just the
chef's differences as in like fast food
items there's some stuff that's been
there for like decades but they change
your local restaurant you'll only
experience it for like two years at a
time because that's why you live there
no no yeah
there's some there are some restaurants
that are just like you never find food
as good as that again i i where
there are some places like anywhere
anywhere you live anywhere you live
every two years or every year yeah but
sometimes you go back to the restaurant
oh that's that's the worst though when
you've been when you go back to your
hometown and there is like this specific
restaurant and it's just changed right
and you'll know you'll never get a taste
of your childhood ever again or you'll
never get a taste of that taste of home
ever again and you didn't know what
before you move that you were saying
goodbye to that piece you were thinking
about the indonesian restaurant at my
local mall in australia the moment that
disappeared i was i had to like hug my
mom i was like it was like losing a
family member i still think when they
change an item of groceries or fast food
is worse because that's something you
have all the time you know like i
remember i used to get dairylee dunkers
all the time in the uk yeah even as an
adult it's like this like i don't know
how to explain it it's called great
it's kind of like um like fake
cheese cream whip um that sounds
disgusting no no no it's not like a whip
though it's like a cheese kind of spread
how would you describe dairyly duncan's
ah
describe it it's kind of like a
breadstick it's like a breadcrumb stick
in one part and then like a cheese kind
of esque thing yeah the other oh
yeah
yeah yeah we have something like that so
they made they made that in the uk right
and but then i think they changed their
recipe when i was like 20 years old
they changed how they made the cheese
and it tasted significantly cheaper
why are we eating that at 20 years of
age don't question why the [ __ ] i was
eating that 20 years because it was
really good like it was a really nice
snack it tasted amazing and i love to
get it and it was a blast of nostalgia
every time right and they had it in my
local supermarket and i would get it and
one time i got it i bought like a full
pack a big like a like a family four
pack i stocked up i was like yeah yeah
i i i dug in right i open it up one bite
and i'm like
something has changed there's been a
disturbance oh geez
isn't that the worst though when and and
then and then at that moment right it's
when you realize yeah i bought a whole
pack at this point so i'm gonna i did it
i was
i i ate another one and i was like
they've changed it they've definitely
changed it i it's definitely not me i
asked my friend i was like listen did
you have the old one they were like yeah
and then i gave it to them and they were
like they were like okay try it try it
now try it like try this new one tell me
if it's changed they're like no it
doesn't taste any different my women's
last time you had it they were like over
a year ago i'm like you wouldn't know
then yeah you wouldn't know because it's
a slow gradual change it's one year you
wouldn't know so i emailed the company
did you actually yeah because i wanted
the nerve they did it i wanted to know
if i was being crazy right
yeah you're definitely [ __ ] crazy
that's for sure who did you email
so
the email on the back of the packet yeah
so they so i found i found the company
online right and this is only because
i wouldn't have done this if my friend
didn't say no they didn't change it i
was like i was like they changed it and
they're like they didn't change it i'm
like they changed it
and so i found out the company it sounds
like a deleted scene from american
psycho yeah
factory and be like tell me the truth
i know you're lying to me i wanted to
know because i wanted to know if i if my
taste buds have changed or if i was
being crazy or if you know i just needed
to know it was driving me insane okay
yeah so i emailed them right no response
and i was like what the [ __ ] so i call
up their customer service because i'm
like now i need to know because i didn't
reply right so i call them up and i ask
them i'm like hey uh so this type of
dairy lee dunker thing did you change
the recipe at any point in recent time
and they were like
hmm
can i get back to you and i was like
you're not gonna get [ __ ] back to it
yeah sorry
oh this is like three years ago oh okay
this is like
and then that wasn't three and i'm still
yeah i gave them my number and they
actually called me back wow wow they
said no
and i was like what no no no no who
would have [ __ ] thought there's a
check i said check here check again
right
so then i was like what the [ __ ] i was
so annoyed man i thought [ __ ] like oh my
god like i [ __ ] it up man why am i an
idiot why did i think it changed yeah
a year later i got an email reply saying
that they had changed one of the like uh
one of the aspects of like the cheese or
something that they did and i was like i
felt vindicated bro i felt like you know
how like when you watch those movies
about someone being wrongly convicted
and caught and then they finally get out
i was i felt like that like i was like
thank you thank you guys i'm finally
free i finally solved the mystery that
they [ __ ] changed it i can't believe
they emailed you back yeah yeah yeah
my god like
that employee must have really [ __ ]
cared you know i don't know why we care
about all our customers i'm not really
sure how that happened there it was
really bizarre somebody like [ __ ]
dusted off their inbox and be like
yeah one guy you know you you met us
last year if the ingredients changed
sorting out the spam form i didn't
expect them to even answer my callback
but the fact they called me back just to
tell me no i was like that's weird
but because you're probably the like one
you're probably the one person to
actually [ __ ] call great customer
service do you have it guys
i've never heard of a single person
actually phoning customer service for
like a food item and you call me a
camera well because no i was it wasn't a
car i was like i don't mean to know i
was like by the way um did you change
the recipe it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter how strongly you say
it what do you mean the fact that you
even [ __ ] did it is like more telling
than am i not i i'm why am i not allowed
to ask that
because it's who cares i care who
actually [ __ ]
it's a cheese stick
that is given to children it is a
literal children's snack you are an
adult i wanted to know
i didn't ask rudely i just asked them
can i by the way just wondering did you
change the recipe
is that rude that's not rude
i don't know man it's not about being
rude it's just like it's strange i
understand yeah it's very strange it's
like there's nothing the determination
what's wrong with that it took like 10
seconds to email them
but the fact that you also called them
up
yeah
i got to know how long did they put you
on hold how long was that no how long
was that running it was interesting
because no one probably calls that knife
because no one's calling them who's
calling them
i could only imagine like the
receptionist to be like
that phone rings
oh they had to blow the dust off it yeah
well because i think what inspired me to
do it is that on on the uk there was a
tv show on uh channel four where they
would they would try and find out where
food items came from
in the uk so like if it was like canned
tomatoes and it would say like made in
like argentina or something yeah they
would just like go on this relentless
triad to go and like [ __ ] find out
where it was it was actually came from
okay and then they would go and visit
the place where it came right
i mean that's interesting yeah i think i
was inspired i was like i want to know
tell me
you know i i understand that it's not
i've never done it since but yeah yeah i
don't think it's i don't think i was
being rude or anything i just asked them
if they changed no it's not i'm not
criticizing you i feel like i've done
something badly here i'm being
criticized [ __ ] you guys i want to know
what my one of my favorite challenges
you're not really criticized for being
rude or anything i'm just like
you were that bored
no it wasn't boredom it was
determination there's a difference i'm
just surprised you were that bored to be
that determined
no i mean i had other stuff to do
i just ignored it
clearly they weren't that important
are you telling me you've never
procrastinated in intriguing ways on
your work yes but
i wish i bet i wish i could say like i
could procrastinate in intriguing ways
no it's never an interesting way if that
is what is the the benchmark for
intriguing
i just load up a meme on youtube and i'm
just like i don't know play a game
you know
you know in some weird way in my head to
justify my my procrastination i feel
like if i've done something that was on
my mind that i wanted to do
it's almost not procrastination in a way
all right like
when i'm supposed sometimes there are
some videos that i don't want to film
because i'm dreading the filming process
because it's quite a difficult video
yeah
i might struggle with it or i'm not too
you know sometimes i'm not like 100 on
the video idea but i don't know until
it's edited right yeah so i kind of
dread it so sometimes i might just put
it off but sometimes it's like great
procrastination like doing my chores i'm
like i'm like this is this is
procrastination that is justified in my
head but i know what is it really no it
is but is it really because i should
have done that one thing but i'm just
i'm i'm lying to myself by doing tasks
that i need to do that i should that
could easily be be done any other time
yeah i'm just pushing forward now
because i don't want to do that one
thing that is procrastination that is
because that's the because that's not a
destination but it's still
procrastinating i don't think there's
such a thing as efficient
procrastination
they're okay there's slightly more
efficient procrastination but at the
same time at the same time you have a
task that you need to do and you are
putting that task off right you can you
can you can you can lie to yourself and
say hey i'm doing something else
productive like cleaning which i do as
well but like i'm just like
sometimes there are videos that you need
to do asap right yeah you're just
putting them off because you don't want
to do it yeah right that's
procrastination regardless of what
you're doing to put it off you know you
could be doing cpr on someone and saving
their life you're still procrastinating
on that video bro let them let them die
bro do the video
i'm kidding you know
if you are you know i would not have
chosen to clean that day the only reason
i chose to clean was because i didn't
want to do the [ __ ] video
i'm procrastinating on that video do you
ever do the cleaning when you don't need
to procrastinate
so so basically you procrastinate on the
cleaning until you try to procrastinate
with something else and then you
procrastinate by cleaning yourself doing
those tasks that you've been putting off
when you really don't want to do
something oh yeah like i just don't lie
to myself horrible i i just don't lie to
myself because i only clean when i'm
procrastinating or making videos right
and then the other day
the the other day um the other day i
just like cleaned my house about five
million times and i ran out of things to
procrastinate on so i made i made this
video called like jojo fans when they
figure out their jokes don't suck dick
and that was made because i was
procrastinating on making videos and i'd
already cleaned the house
so like
it's really screaming at the bottom of
the barrier that is still
procrastinating yeah i know he's still
procrastinating that's what i'm saying
you just said it wasn't you said it
wasn't no i'm saying like there's no
such thing ever like every
procrastination is made equal is it
procrastination if it's monetizable
yes
yes it's still procrastination okay i
was trying to help you man
i threw the rope and you threw it back
at me what the [ __ ]
no i'm i'm arguing about jerry when you
don't want to film a video oh sorry
you're arguing i'm arguing that all
procrastinally all procrastination is
made the same it's it's essentially
essentially you are putting something an
important that's what i argued and you
disagreed with me oh you said you said
that you can like min max
procrastination right there no no no i
said you're still procrastinating even
if you're like cleaning that's still
procrastinating that's what i argue that
oh i thought you never said it was good
i thought you were just arguing the
opposite no okay why didn't you say that
at all i said listen to me god this is
why they trust his podcast his arguments
because god
no one [ __ ] listens i understand [ __ ]
you you're wrong you know i just wanted
to disagree with you connor [ __ ]
i literally said your point
i was like hold on for a second i had to
readjust for yeah i was like halfway
through that conversation i'm like you
just made the same point what the [ __ ]
you all about so i was just back to the
[ __ ] day already
like my mind was just like i can't
believe it's like uh the baby bells do
you have those in australia yeah [ __ ]
love baby bars i miss those man nothing
beats cheese string we've talked about
this not nothing beats cheese string
cheese cheese strings on another level
but baby bell's next in line yeah this
is american i have baby baby well this
talk of food is making me [ __ ]
starving i'm starving
food
[ __ ] episode
salad wasn't enough for me earlier today